[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
anouk anti sous marine ou voit un beau
immeuble est casa thé alcool coule et
toutes qualités l'obus ce loto un beau
buzz circulation est clos de l essence 2
min pour mana zot bann marmay i jouait
dans le parc pas madame de monde est
pressé pour aller travailler bien y
passe de signer cet effet des hommes
insectes ont mené n'apparaît ni danse
pour nous à le canton gosport mis en
pause 9e pas voilà veut il passe une
tête qui réveille à nous qui fait
désordre et demi nous avons deux animaux
et champagne en plus il fait peur aux
chiens que des régions où ils n'aiment
pas voir ni dans la rue ni ses macbook
air n'est même pas venu d'egypte lui
même nature à vous passer la destinée de
penser que de vos doutes et
irresponsable que va t il faire il nous
fait peut-être que votre fiche de voix
donne un album à nous attisé ma vie nous
voudraient sent un peu le ventre de la
boutique
en résumé c'est d'être au serbe il
arrive donc en partie responsables
voudraient la société qui leur viennent
une rythmique nos difficultés
nous voudrons aref la maltraitance de
tout demoun nous voudraient l'égalité
des salaires entre condom enfin nous
voudrait
un salaire pourquoi
allez les gones
[Musique]
je pense il n'y en pas nous on voudrait
ne viennent pas nous voir nous vaudreuil
et champagne où les bannis
[Musique]